I always tell this story I teach a lot  at Harvard MIT all these places I'll  never forget it this guy puts up his  hand who hasn't contributed anything all  night he says listen I gotta ask you a  question I've been running this business  out of my dorm I'm making about 5  million a year in free cash flow my  fiancee came to me today and said that  she's going to leave me because I'm not  spending any time with her family I  don't have any time on weekends I just  can't because I'm so busy what do I do  now the class is like you could hear a  pin drop in there and I said to him wow  okay I'm not Dr Phil but let me give you  some advice here which one is easier to  replace the girlfriend or the business  I mean you gotta ask that question